most of us probably don't like it when
people get hurt but something about
violence definitely fascinates all of us
think about high school that fight that
broke out during lunch and you just had
to get on a table to get a good view or
the last time you saw a car crash and
you couldn't help but stare out the
window to see how about the accident was
or the last time you paid money to see
people fight it seems like we actually
enjoy seeing violence let's start with
fist fights in high school sometimes
these fights even got bloody but in
general I don't recall a lot of concern
from other students as much as
fascination myself included Andrews says
administrators try to break up fights
before that can happen this video shows
a principal trying to protect the victim
24 students reportedly suspended ten of
which were on the football team parents
say they want more at the very least
they want change to make sure something
like this doesn't happen again there
isn't a lot of research on fistfight
specifically but according to data from
the CDC at least 425 people were killed
by being struck by hands or feet in 2016
and this data only accounts for 32
states in the u.s. trauma expert Duncan
Butte told BBC that people are very much
focused on penetrating injuries but
actually punching somebody in the head
can be just as lethal
in a question I can't help but asking
myself is if this is part of our nature
according to author John Gaucho many
animals from bears to shrimp have
dueling behaviors that seemed to mirror
human fighting and a study published in
2013 found that human hands might
actually have evolved to make it easier
for us to punch the research indicated
that while both slaps and punches
produced the same amount of force the
fist allows us to protect our fingers
while hitting a smaller surface layer
making it easier for us to inflict more
damage on the opponent but even if the
intent isn't necessarily to kill or
severely injure a we crazy for being
drawn to violence communications and
psychology professor Brad Bushman told
CNN that violence has been used as
entertainment throughout human history
he explained that in ancient Egypt
people would watch others from an egg
god Osiris murder the gladiator games in
Rome were also another example of
ancient violent entertainment and now we
have the UFC for instance UFC president
Dana White explained to CNN everybody
loves a fight it's in our DNA if you're
in an intersection and there's a
basketball game in one corner a soccer
game on another a baseball game on the
3rd and a fight on the fort everybody
will watch the fight and that's not only
true but it's something that cuts across
all demographic and geographic barriers
I guess this kind of makes sense I could
go somewhere across the world and not
understand a thing about what I'm seeing
but a physical fight is the dynamic that
I could easily pick up on and sort of
understand with no context and quite
frankly be very interested professor and
author Christian launch says that
violence is a universal language and it
universally explores the body but is
violence really a universal language or
have we made it one by normalizing it in
order to get more perspective about how
violence relates to human behavior I
reached out to David we were to settle
the emotion of anger is unquestionably
universal I mean as mammals were all
wired to feel angry it's part of the
limbic system and there's a guy named
Ekman who in the 70s went around the
whole world to different cultures and he
showed them photos to a list at a
feeling and he noticed that the same
muscles on the face light up wherever
you go in the world if you go to Japan
you go to New Guinea you go to Germany
you go to these very different cultures
when someone is purely
angry or purely sad the same muscles in
the face light up but different cultures
mask emotion in different ways The
Washington Post reported that the global
market is the engine behind Hollywood's
assembly line production of violent
action films and a study published in
2017 found that violence results in
increased movie ticket sales
particularly in pg-13 movies
so are we normalizing violence or is
this just a reflection of our human
nature as reported by the American
Psychological Association there's
increasing evidence that exposure to
violence within the media one consumes
in childhood and adolescence can be a
contributing factor to developing
aggressive habits and according to
Michelle garrison young children
problematically see good guys use
methods of violence as a means of
problem-solving for instance superhero
movies where the good guy can hurt the
bad guy without any negative
repercussion and not seeing any physical
effects of that violence on the bad guy
[Music]
you know anger is a normal emotion and
we have the possibility of feeling you
know rage really high levels of feeling
and I think that I think that many
people have a wish to be able to let
loose of some of these really powerful
feelings and to see another person up
there really letting go
I think fulfills some of the fantasies
and wishes that we all carry and so it's
really you know when you watch a movie
someone just pummels someone else or
there's like MMA fighting this is a real
fascination I think about it
all in all this all still leaves me
wondering if entertainment is violent
because we enjoy violence or the other
way around and more importantly how is
this affecting us now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]